i'm hosting the spirit awards and i'm
trying to do like a
promising and woman thing as you may
have noticed we are not in the big tent
on the beach
i wish that we could all be there in
person rather than
me talking into a phone but this is the
deal tonight we celebrate the directors
writers and actors who embody the spirit
of independent film
and the spirit award for best male lead
goes to
riz ahmed best female lead goes to
carrie mulligan
best director goes to chloe joe
for nomad land the independent spirit
awards now officially cover
tv and still cover film yay
best female performance in a new
scripted series
shira haas for unorthodox
[Music]
so a lot of thank yous i want to thank
my fellow nominees for their beautiful
work and i'm so humbled to be in your
company
independent film is so much fun because
you get to be on summer camp with people
independent films where we all learn our
craft is where we grow our crafts where
we can take risks
even though without money without time
and you film independent you are a
community and we are so honored to be
recognized
by our tribe now that i've gone through
the process of making this film
i'm even more emboldened to bring
stories to screen film independent the
spirit awards has
always promoted diverse voices
independent spirit awards let's all sign
that together
was it magic or was it the independent
spirits that did it
i'm so moved by this award thank you so
so much
i'm so happy
thank you in every possible language
you